one thing I want to talk about is the
duration of how long to take vitamin D
as well as the dosage there's a lot of
confusion
most people are taking between 600 IU's
to a thousand I use sometimes 2,000 IU's
and they think that that's enough one
thing you need to realize is that about
75% of the population on planet Earth
are deficient in vitamin D and vitamin D
is so important in fact it's the most
important fat soluble vitamin especially
for the immune system based on some
pretty credible studies which I'm going
to list down below and I only listed
three I'm gonna give you quite a few of
them in the first study the group took a
thousand 2,000 IU's of vitamin D once -
twice per week for one month and did not
increase their vitamin D levels at all
second study took a thousand of 2,000
IU's
and it took four months to elevate their
vitamin D and in the third study it took
three months to achieve just a normal
level of vitamin D by taking 1,600 IUs
of vitamin D and I just had a call from a
lady on my live show who was taking
50,000 I used a vitamin D for weeks and
it did not even increase her levels so
the question is how could you be that
deficient if you're taking so much
vitamin D the first thing to know is
that it takes a lot longer than you
think
to fix a vitamin D deficiency it could
take months the second thing to know is
that there are various things that
prevent the absorption of vitamin D one
is your gut if your gut has damaged
you're not going to be able to absorb
out them and eat you well also your age
greatly influences your ability to
absorb vitamin D not just from dietary
sources but from the Sun the color of
your skin also influences your ability
to absorb vitamin D in other words if
the skin is darker it could take three
times as much Sun to penetrate the skin
and then there's a topic of how much fat
you have the more subcutaneous fat you
have in your body
the less you're going to absorb vitamin
D and then there's exposure to the Sun
if you're going out in the Sun
and you're only exposing your hands and
your face of the Sun you're only
exposing 5% of your body to the Sun
which it would take you hours and hours
and hours to even achieve a small amount
of vitamin D and then you have the
location where you live the latitude the
connection between where you live in the
Sun if you live in the northern
hemisphere which if we look at United
States is just above LA and we look at
the months between November and March
the amount of vitamin D you're going to
get is pretty much insignificant and
then we have metabolic issues let's say
for example you have diabetes you have
arthritis you have high blood pressure
cardiovascular disease guess what the
requirements for vitamin D go way way up
and then of course we have the season if
it's winter and you're out there trying
to get Sun the odds of you getting
enough vitamin D are very very slim and
then lastly there's a genetic factor
involved called polymorphism where there
is a variant or an alteration in your
genes which don't allow you to absorb
vitamin D very well and a lot of people
have this and they don't even know they
have it
and that could be the reason why they
can't absorb it oh and there's one more
that I forgot to mention if you have a
chronic infection see the viruses that
invade the body downgrade your vitamin D
receptor so if you have an infection
whether it's in the lung and the sinuses
or in your gut the microbes specifically
viruses have a strategy of blocking the
absorption of vitamin D they block the
receptor so you can't absorb it it's a
survival mechanism and the white blood
cells that are fighting the virus need
vitamin D desperately so they're gonna
suck up that last a little bit of
vitamin D that you have so as you can
see there's a lot of factors involved
with the absorption of vitamin D how
much vitamin D would I recommend 10,000
IU's per day as a maintenance and I
mentioned this plus if there's an
autoimmune issue involved and you're
gonna need much higher amounts of
vitamin D with magnesium b6 and zinc and
there's a couple other things that you
can do if you're concerned
that this amount of vitamin D is toxic
which is not you'd have to consume one
to 200,000 IUs of vitamin D for months
and months or years to create the
complications and the biggest
complication from vitamin D toxicity is
hypercalcemia that's too much calcium in
the blood because that could be to
kidney stones one way to even minimize
the risk for that would be to drink 2.5
litres of water per day that way you
avoid a super concentration of calcium
in the kidney so there won't be any
calcium forming in the kidney another
way is just to avoid calcium and
supplements as well as cheese that way
there's no calcium to go into the kidney
in form as a kidney stone alright guys
thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains no sugar
totally keto there's no suffering on keto
absolutely not Karen and it's an immune
system builder absolutely you have to
check this out I think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple
we hope you enjoy making it as much as we
are enjoying eating